Sometimes actors are so great at their jobs
that we forget they’re acting.
Add a cape and some tights to the equation
and us mere mortals don’t stand a chance.
Performers are presented as larger than life,
and combined with all the glitz and glamour
of Hollywood magic, it’s easy to forget
that underneath they’re skin and bone just
like us.
So we wanted to take a second to remind everyone
that yes, celebs are people too.
Before we jump into the good stuff, we wanted
to thank you for watching our video.
If you like what you see, go over to our channel
and check out some of our other fare.
You can subscribe with the click of a button,
and with just one more click you can join
the notification squad.
That way you’ll be the first one to know
when we post new content.
You’re just two clicks away from paradise.
And hey, here’s something to keep you thinking:
can you guess the movie from these emojis?
Stay tuned for the answer, and some other
fun trivia questions along the way.
Here are 10 Marvel Superhero Actors Who Are
Weaker Than You Think.
Ryan Reynolds
Deadpool is a lot of things, but sadly, “invincible”
is not one of them.
And even though he’s injured himself playing
someone ‘super’ before, Ryan Reynolds
still gave one hundred and ten percent on
set.
And that might actually be the problem.
The actor was so into the character that his
enthusiasm took its toll on his body.
Reynolds broke bones, separated his shoulders,
and came home with a headache on more than
one occasion.
With all the spectacle that comes along with
a blockbuster production, it’s easy to forget
that at the end of the day, everyone is capable
of getting hurt.
Even if they do have an insane set of abs.
Chris Pratt
It’s no secret that Chris Pratt looks a
lot different than he used to.
If you don’t know what we mean, just compare
early seasons of Parks and Rec to his turn
in Guardians of the Galaxy.
While a lot of conversations these days center
around Hollywoods unrealistic expectations
for women, the leading men are not immune
— no matter how amazing they are.
Landing the role of Starlord was a turning
point in the actors career.
Pratt went from looking like a run of the
mill, average dude to ripped behemoth in a
matter of months.
And he’s been pumping that iron ever since.
Chris Hemsworth
Here’s a name you wouldn’t normally associate
with weakness: Thor.
Well, Thor isn’t real.
But the man playing him sure is.
Chris Hemsworth comes from a long line of
civil servants, and is the son of two social
workers.
When the god of thunder isn’t smashing his
hammer around, he works as an ambassador for
the Australian Childhood Foundation.
Turns out, being a softie comes naturally
to the blonde bruiser.
The had to learn the ass-kicking part.
So if Chris Hemsworth has a weakness for anything,
it’s his fellow humans.
Mark Ruffalo
Bruce Banner is an intimidating hothead, which
is great if you’re a bouncer, not so great
if you’re a scientist.
In addition to broken Erlenmeyer flasks and
smashed microscopes, it’s just not fun to
work alongside a temperamental jerk.
But in real life, Mark Ruffalo is on the opposite
end of the emotional spectrum.
He’s a vocal activist for clean water and
renewable energy.
And recently stood in solidarity with members
of the Standing Rock Sioux to protest construction
of an oil pipeline through their territory.
The actor understands the power of celebrity,
and chooses to throw his weight behind causes
near and dear to his heart.
Jeremy Renner
A large part of what makes superheroes “super”
is their ability to run into the middle of
a brawl and shut it down before emerging unharmed.
Yes, being super is a dangerous job, but that’s
not a reason to avoid it.
Unless you’re a human.
But it seems we mortals just can’t seem
to stay out of the way and let the heroes
sort it out.
And we get hurt a lot as a result.
This is exactly what happened to earthling
Jeremy Renner while filming The Avengers.
According to Joss Whedon, the actor hurt his
back and shoulder so badly that the movie’s
production had to shut down for days afterward.
Hopefully he has insurance.
Scarlett Johansson
We’ve already established that being cast
in a superhero movie is a blessing and a curse.
On the upside: the pay is decent, millions
of people will see your work, learn your name,
and talk about you incessantly on the internet
for years to come.
The downside?
Permanent injury.
After five appearances as the Black Widow,
and a few more to come, Scarlett Johansson
knows this better than anyone.
She’s had more than a few bumps and bruises
by this point.
And has joked in interviews about how she’ll
be rehabbing them for the rest of her life.
Tom Hiddleston
Tom Hiddleston may be equally known for his
roles as Loki in the MCU, and as Taylor Swift’s
ex-boyfriend, depending on who you are.
Either way, it might be tempting to look at
him as a cool guy to end all cool guys — which
would be a mistake.
The actor is big into music, and can play
a ton of different instruments.
Piano, trumpet, violin and lute, just to name
a few.
And according to his IMDb page, his “eyes
water involuntarily when spooked”, whatever
that means.
So the next time you get a little spooked
about Loki’s ability to read your mind or
beat you senseless, remember this: if the
MCU was high school, he’d be the one spending
his entire day stuffed in a locker.
Samuel L. Jackson
If Samuel L. Jackson has a trademark, it’s
his voice.
He’s almost always yelling, and nobody can
drop an f-bomb like he can.
The actor’s tirades are the highlight of
any movie he’s in, and he’s so confident
that you’d have to be a straight up fool
to challenge him.
But Jackson wasn’t always like that.
Growing up, the actor had a speech impediment.
But he handled it the way he handles everything
— by facing it head on.
After performing in a few plays during his
youth, and working his butt off, Jackson’s
stutter went away.
Immersion therapy at its finest.
Chris
Evans
When it comes to Chris Evans, “weak” is
the wrong word to use.
“Soft”, maybe, but not weak.
Why?
Well it turns out that Captain America is
a HUGE fan of The Little Mermaid.
Apparently he knows every single song by heart,
and could act the whole thing out with his
eyes closed.
That last part doesn’t really surprise us,
he is an actor after all.
But even though he’s most known for playing
a character who could beat us all up, Evans
is a big softie.
Dudes who pride themselves on machismo will
probably bristle at this revelation.
And even though he looks the type, the actor
doesn’t fit the mould of a “manly man”.
Which is just fine by us.
Robert Downey Jr.
If you’re one of those people who believes
that addiction is a choice, then you probably
don't look too kindly upon Robert Downey Jr’s
past.
But as the Iron Man actor has stated time
and time again in interviews: he is not his
story.
Growing up, RDJ was dealt a tough hand.
And, like many people do, he coped with the
assistance of drugs and alcohol.
But the actor has devoted the last few decades
to sobriety, and worked incredibly hard to
get where he is today.
So rather than seeing his journey as a weakness,
maybe people should be marveling at his tenacity
and self-preservation instead.
What do you think?
Do you know of any other actors in the MCU
who don’t quite match up to their on screen
personas?
We want to hear from you, so tell us about
them in the comments.
If you liked this video, head on over to our
channel where you can subscribe and join the
notification squad.
That way, when we post new stuff, you’ll
be the first to know.
You’ll probably like our friends over at
CBR too, so go show them some love.
Thanks for watching.